Starting broadcast.
All right.
Live stream is starting soon.
We got people in the house.
Hello world. It's Raj.
Good to see everybody.
We are here or I am here
in Portland, Oregon. Uh,
just for a week just to check it out,
see what it's like here.
It's actually pretty cool up here in
the Pacific northwest. Hi everybody.
I'm going to list some names.
Uh, everybody who's here.
Alexandros Radu Marco Max.
David said to Raphael for Ya.
Sausa hi everybody.
So Yasha um,
today we are going to,
uh,
make a bot for the game of
asteroids and we're going to,
uh, have it get better and better at
the game until it's able to beat it.
And it's going to use a
technique called neuro evolution.
It's called neuro evolution. Okay.
Uh, that's the name of this technique.
And uh, we're going to do
this in javascript. Okay.
And this is a part of a collaboration
with another youtuber named Daniel
Shiffman, uh, that I am excited to do.
Okay. So that's what we're going to do.
I'm going to start off with a
five minute Q and a like always.
And then we're going to get started
with the code. All right, here we go.
Five minute Q and. A. Let's do
this. I'm doing pretty well.
I'm excited to be here in Portland.
I'm going to make an
experimental video here.
Is Dan joining live?
Know which tool do we have to use?
It's going to be just pure
javascript neural evolution.
Like a genetic algorithm. Yes. Hi
from Israel. Did you go to nips?
I didn't go to nips. I didn't go to
nips. But next time I will for sure.
Are you building the game to not the game,
just the Ai Code.
You should come on up to Seattle. I
would love to. I would love to, um,
advice for upcoming computer scientists.
Um, find a paper that you really like,
just find a paper that you really
like and then try to replicate it.
And then if you need help using an
advisor or someone who has a lot of
experience. But I found that replicating
papers has gotten me really good,
really fast. Uh, add a lot of, uh, at
least for ml, and I'm sure, I mean,
the same can be applied to computer
science theory. What do you do?
Saroj I do this youtube channel
fulltime. Any news about rocket AI? Guys,
I'm sorry to break the news for you,
but rocket AI is a total hoax.
It's not real that everybody was in on
it. They trolled everybody. Tim portally,
recurrent optimal learning
troll. Okay. That's the acronym.
Are you drinking coffee?
Yes.
What can a high school do in
machine learning right now? Um,
you can get started with TF,
learn or a psychic learn.
Those are two great libraries
to get started with.
Find a Dataset on Kaggle and then run a
model on it and see what you can find.
Well, you ever cover where you cover
other AI concepts beyond neural networks?
Absolutely. Um, tensorflow
versus care Os. Um,
tensorflow, which AI tool will you
be using in this video? I'm not.
I'm using pure javascript. Um, uh,
please buster wrap on screen right now.
I will say that till the end for the end.
Uh,
papers from where I triple e archive.
Arx id.org archive is a good place.
Shall I tweet you for technical help?
Yes. You can tweet me at the same time.
Remember we have a community guys.
It's not just me.
We're all here to help each other learn.
So there's a slack channel with
a link in all of my videos,
so all remember to always ask
questions there as well. Um,
two more questions and then we're going
to get started. Thanks to Alexander. Uh,
is that a promise about busing the wrap?
Yesterday's did you please remind me
though difference between Siri and Google?
Uh, Siri is a worse in every
way because like, wow, apple,
you just totally missed the boat on AI
and just now you just like publish your
first paper. Congrats. Um, but Google now
is just like way better. Like they're,
they're the, the learning algorithms
they have the data that it's trained on.
It's just way more. What do you think
about octave? It's not that great.
How do I implement decompression by
song? Hahn? Deep compression? Well,
first of all, anything with
compression and neural networks,
it has to do with an auto encoder.
So you're probably going
to use an auto encoder.
The word deep implies many layers.
So like lots of layers and
the specific one that he made,
I haven't seen, but show me a Lincoln,
then I might make a video on it. Okay.
So those are my questions.
Those are my questions. Um,
now we're going to get
started with the code. Okay.
So I'm going to go ahead and screen share.
Let's do this.
All right,
so I want to start off by showing you
guys a demo of this code so you can see
what it looks like. Okay. I'm going
to show you guys a demo of this code.
So, oh, look like this.
So what happens is,
okay,
uh, Amy ass playing and
many different generations,
many different, uh, space,
uh, ships are created. Uh,
this is, so, this is neuro evolution.
I'm going to talk about what's
happening here, but as you can see,
it's just there are a lot of
them that are being spawned,
a lot of ships and they're
all trying different moves.
And the one that has the best move is
the one that's going to survive and
reproduce and create a better one.
And so over time it's going to get better.
But you can see here that the basic
idea I want to show you by looking,
by showing you this, uh, game is that, uh,
these things get better over
time and there are many of them,
many of them that respond. Okay?
So that's the basic idea. I'm,
the link will be in the code.
Okay?
Okay.
Are we lagging? We're lagging. Cool. Okay,
so now let's go ahead and
get started with this. Um,
I'm going to go ahead and
get started with the code.
I'll make this bigger so
everybody can see what I'm typing.
So this is going to be neuro evolution.
That's the technique we're
using is the technique.
Okay? So that's a technique that
we're going to be using. And uh, yeah,
so there's that. And so, so that's what
we're going to do. And so what happened?
What's happening here is like what most,
uh,
learning methods focus on modifying just
the strength of the neural connections.
Uh, this doesn't, this modifies not
just, uh, the neuro connections.
It modifies the actual
structure of the network.
So adding neurons, um, it's, uh,
adding connections. It's uh, and even, uh,
modifies the learning rates.
So a lot of hyper parameters are modified
by this. It's not just the connections.
So that's what makes it different
from like, from regular,
uh, backpropagation. Uh,
okay, so bigger font, okay,
let me make it a little bigger.
Okay. Boom. That's a technique that
we're going to be learning. Uh,
and this is a type of
reinforcement learning.
This is a type of reinforcement learning
that's we're going to be learning right
now. And because it's happening
through trial and error, uh,
so what's going to happen
is we're going to do,
and the reason we're doing this is because
the optimal actions at each point in
time are not always known. Like, remember,
this is a game. This is a game. Uh,
things are random.
Things are random.
And neuro evolution proves to be a
good technique for this because it,
you're able to optimize behavior
given only a sparks feedback.
So as far as feedback is
available is available.
All right?
Um,
okay.
But that's what's happening
here. So, so the steps are,
we're going to do this
in increasing order.
So we're going to go ahead and create
art, neuro evolution, uh, object.
But in that we're going to
create increasingly larger, uh,
objects. So the first one is the
neuron and the next one is the layer,
then it's going to be the network,
then the genome,
and then finally the generations.
So as you can see,
each of these gets bigger over time.
So I'm,
so we'll create new revolution
as our big master object.
Then we're going to create a
neuron, a. And so a neuron it,
there are many neurons inside
of a layer of a network.
And then there are many
layers inside of a network.
And then each network
is considered a geno.
A genome is another word for
individual or being in a, in,
in what's called a generation.
Okay? So there's a generation,
a generation has multiple genomes.
Each genome has its own neural network.
Each neural network has its own set of
layers and each layer has it's own set of
neurons. Okay? So it's all
obstructions. Okay? Everything is, um,
all right, everything is just
like this. All right? So,
so that's what's happening
right now in sports.
Feedback means that you
don't have a lot of feedback.
Like you don't have a lot of data. The
word sparts is applied to data. What?
We don't have a lot of it. So if there's
a lot of zeroes in our data, uh, that,
that would be sparse. Okay? So let's go
ahead and get started by doing this. Um,
all right, so let's go ahead
and create our first variable.
It's called neuro evolution,
neuro evolution.
That is our big master variable and it's
going to be a function and we're going
to get options.
So what are these options?
Options are another word
for hyper parameters.
And I'm going to talk about what the
specific hyper parameters are for this.
Okay? So we're going to start off by
defining defining ourself self variable.
By calling this, okay,
that's the first step.
Now we want to create those
options. So remember, options are,
are hyper parameters,
um,
is unsupervised learning.
Indeed. Exactly. Um, options are,
are hyper parameters.
So we're going to start off by saying
the first option we want is our sigmoid
function. Let me talk about
what the sigmoid function is,
but first let me type it out. So sigma
is an activation function, okay? Um,
sigma is an activation function and it's
a function that we run in every neurono
bar network. Okay? So let
me write, write this out.
I'm going to create a variable called
AP that is negative a over one.
And then I'm going to return this
equation. What does this equation, well,
this is the actual sigmoid equation
and it is a static equation.
Let me explain the hyper
parameters in a second.
But this is a static equation and what
it's doing is it's converting every
number into a set up into a probability.
So this,
this sigmoid is run in,
this function is run in every
neuron of our network, okay?
And it's how we can convert our numbers
into probabilities. Return. Okay,
return.
What are hyper printers?
Hyper parameters are the tuning knobs of
our network. They change over time. Okay?
They are the tuning knobs of our network.
We could change what they are. Okay?
And I'm going to show you a list
of hyper parameter in a second.
The next function we want to create,
it's called random clamps. Okay?
Random. Uh, it's called random clamped.
And what this function does is it returns
a random value and we can use that to
generate weights as well.
So that's a different point,
but we're going to use this to generate
a set of weights later, okay? And
okay,
so there's that.
And I want to return math dot random.
We're going to use the random function.
We're going multiply it
by two to make sure it,
that the number is big enough for
us. And it's a crack by. Whoa. Okay.
So there's those,
there's that.
Now we're going to create our
list of hypochlor amateurs.
The first one is going to be a population,
which is the size of our population,
right? How big do we want
this, this population to be?
The next one is called elite elitism.
What? It's Alita zone. This is the,
this is the number that we're
going to apply to each of. So, so,
so elitism is whenever, um, we are,
uh, so let me give you a quick
explanation of, of, of, of uh,
genetic programming for a second
genetic algorithms. So you,
you have a population,
so it's step one is a,
you have a population and then what
happened is they performed crossover,
which is they, they, they breed together
and then the end result is then you,
those children and you keep going,
right? There are three, right? So, so,
so you select the best ones selection
and then you perform crossover.
You take those and you make them.
And I'm going to show you guys what mate
means in this context and then we're
going to mutate them.
And so this is what elite tourism does.
Elitism is dealing with the mutation.
Polytheism means we're taking
how w 20%. Right? At 0.2.
So we're going to take 20% of
the best offspring. Okay? Um,
okay.
So that's what's going to be happening.
Um,
so right now we're going
to say random behavior is,
is going to be a 0.2. Okay.
So what does random behavior,
um, ran behavior is the new
random networks for the next
generation. So the rate,
so how, how, how, how random
do we want this to be? Right?
The next one is the mutation rates.
You Taishan rate is saying, uh,
what the, the rate of the, that
we're updating the synapsis, how,
how much do we want to mutate them? Okay.
And then we have a mutation range. Okay.
Uh, why the tradeoff between
20%? Good question. Uh,
20% as opposed to something larger,
like I don't know, more than 50.
You want something that's less than 50,
because you only want the best ones,
you only want the best ones and you
want to diminish the rate, uh, that,
that you want to diminish the,
the rate that the population is,
is a breeding so that by the
time your son, uh, first of all,
it's faster that the network trains
faster and you only have a few at the end.
Okay.
Um,
okay.
Okay. So there's that. So the
mutation range is going to be 0.5.
Then we have our actual network. So
the network is going to be one. Uh,
and so what is the network?
Well, now I'm defining, um,
now I'm defining the size of the network.
What does that mean? It means, uh,
uh, like the, the structure of the
neural network. I want one layer. Okay.
I went three of them. So this is a three
layer feed forward neural network. Okay?
So that's the network. And let me define
that as an array. So that's an array.
And so now we want another
hyper parameter called historic,
which saves the adult,
the latest generation that's safe.
That's what it's going in store.
What's the last generation?
Right now we'll initialize it as
zero because there are no, uh,
generations right now.
The next one is going to be low historic.
So we're only going to save
this the score, right? It's
a boolean that says like,
we're only going to save this score.
Now we want to sort sort it, right?
So we want to sort it
up till negative ones.
So what order do we want
this sort things in?
We're going to sort it right now in the
sending wardrobe because it's negative
one. If we wanted it to be
positive, we would do positive
one. Okay. This is a Bot.
So now and be trialed one.
All right,
so this is the number of children
that we want to breathe. Okay.
So that's it for our a hyper parameters.
Let me just move that up,
that different hyper parameters and
now we can go ahead and initialize.
Yes. All right, so let me go ahead
and move that here. I see. Okay.
So now we're going initialize our are
set variables to have options available.
Okay. So what is this?
Now I'm going to um,
behave. Oh, good call typo
on behavior. Behavior.
All right, great. And
variables. No variable. It's
not very, almost scary though.
So we want to create a sense, what do I
mean by a sec? We want to set up options.
We're going to initialize
that like this. Um, okay.
So, um, so now that we've
initialize our variables,
we're going to say, we're going to
loop, we're going to do in this loop,
we're going to say for every option that
we have, for every option that we have,
I want you to do to, uh, say if, if,
if there's nothing there right now,
then I want you to fill it into our
existing list of, of options. Okay.
Uh,
got to add those in.
Okay. So I've got up
my comments here. Okay.
So then if the option is there
and it's not defined undefined,
then we are going to add it
to our options are ray. Okay?
So we want every option to be,
uh, in my options are ray. Okay?
So options up til I, alright, so now,
um, so there's that. And so
now let's create our neurons.
We're going to create our
neuron. Um, all right,
so our neuron is going to be,
um,
it's going to be a function to, so the
neuron has an internal value and as,
as it has a set of connections to every
other neuron in the next layer. Okay.
So we're going to define
both of those to, uh, uh, uh,
both of those two variables. Okay?
So the first one is the value.
It's going to be zero. Like what
is the value of this neuron? Well,
if we're going to initialize it a zero
and then the weights or connections to
every other node,
which we were going to store in
an array which is empty right now,
the next step is going to be to
randomly initialized our weight values.
Uh, we want, we want them to be distinct.
We want them to be distinct,
okay?
All right? So now we want
them to be distinct, right?
So let's go ahead and do this.
So the first one we're going to
do is we're going to create a,
we're going to create a neuron.
It's going to be a prototype objects,
which is the higher level, uh,
object. And we're going to,
we're going to create our
population function, okay?
Or we're going to populate it,
but,
and we're going to do this by randomly
initializing wait values, okay?
So let me show you what I mean by this.
Well initialize a function and the
perimeter is going to be n be okay,
which is, uh, the number of weights that
we once a why randomize the weights?
Uh, because, uh, well
I mean there are many,
many methods of like,
like how do initial initialize
weights random is the most popular,
but there could be a better,
a more, uh, more, uh,
more, uh, efficient way of
doing that. But right now, uh,
and that's an area of research as well,
but generally we randomly initialized
our weights and then we make them better
over time. But just like randomly
sampling data, uh, it could be,
we could do that better as
well, but random is just an
easy way to, to start off.
Okay. So we'll initialize
our, uh, weights array and uh,
we're going to iterate through
every week that we're given.
So bar I equals to zero.
I is less than the number of weights.
And then I've left plus, okay. I put flux.
So we're going to say add every weight
to the list of weights that we have and
what are we using?
We're using that random clamped function
to add a randomly initialized set of
weights to our weights array.
Okay, so that's for our neuron.
Now let's do our layer.
Remember we're increasing the size of,
of how big we are in a of the objects
that we are creating every time.
So we did our weights and now
we're going to do our layer.
And the layer has an ID and a number of
neurons. Okay? Those are, it's too, uh,
attributes,
an ID and a number of neurons.
So we'll start off by creating our layer.
Uh,
and I'll definitely do a recap
at the end of the code. Uh,
so we'll start off with creating a layer.
And a rent a layer is going
to be initialized by this
index variable that is the
parameter of the index parameter.
And what does that mean? Well,
that's going to give us our ID.
That's how we initially,
that's how we identified this layer,
right?
So it's going to be index or zero.
Okay.
And so then we want to initialize
our neurons. How many do we have?
We create a layer, none. So it's still
gonna be an empty list. Okay. It's an, uh,
it's going to be an empty list.
Now we are going to create our layer
prototype prepopulating the lake. Okay.
So we're going to populate the layer with,
um,
thank you for that. Uh,
options. That was a typo.
Now we're going to populate the
layer, uh, with neurons, okay.
Which we've just created. We've
just created neurons, okay.
Layered up prototype to populate.
Uh, and we want there to be
two parameters, the number of
neurons and the number of inputs.
What are the input going to be?
It's going to be the set of actions
that we take during the game. Okay?
That's what we're going
to update our way Twitter.
So we're going to initialize an array
of neurons and we're going to say,
okay, so we're going to iterate through
every single one of our neurons and we're
going to add them all
to our layer. Okay? Um,
let me see this question. Can a layer be
iterated or is it explicitly specified?
We can, uh, we can iterate through
the layer. Um, generally, uh,
in machine learning, we don't update
the number of neurons inside of a layer.
We don't update the actual layer
itself other than the, uh, weights.
But in this case,
in neuro evolution as opposed to just
regular backpropagation neural evolution
in neuro evolution,
we modify all parts of the network.
We can modify the number
of neurons in each layer.
We can modify the number of layers, all,
nothing is safe from neuro revolution.
Okay? So it's not just backpropagation,
we were not just updating the weights.
We're updating the entire neural net,
okay?
So we're going to iterate through the
number of neurons and we're going to say
initialize our first neuron. It's
going to be a new neuron object, okay?
So we're going to say we want a
new neuron. And this is, remember,
this is a class that we've just created
and we want to use that populate
function that we already wrote,
given the number of inputs, okay?
So that's the parameter
for that populate function.
And then when we're done with
that, once we populated, uh, uh,
the number of neurons, we can just
push those neurons, uh, to this,
this layers, uh, array. Okay. So we can
just by using the push function, okay.
So that's our layer and now
we're going to go even higher.
What was the next step? The network,
right? We've created our neurons,
we've created our layers, and the next
step is the actual networking sets. Okay.
And a network consists of layers.
So it's initialized our network, uh,
variable by saying, well, what does
a network habits think about this?
A network has a set of layers. That's
it's though that's the activity that has.
So we'll initialize a layers, a
parameter. Okay. So the number of layers.
MMM.
And now that we've initialize that,
let's go ahead and create a prototype for,
uh, giving it the layer parameters. Okay.
So we're going to call this prototype.
Um,
we're going to call this prototype,
uh,
perceptron generation. Okay. Because
that's another word for neural net.
Perceptron although it's not as sexy,
like people don't use it as much.
But whenever, um, you know,
usually whenever genetic
algorithms come into play,
someone like throws around
the word perceptron. Uh,
but I think neuro evolution
in genetic programming,
it's going to make a huge comeback.
Like, like it had a taytay in the 80s,
and then people kind of gave up with it.
But like,
I think we're going to
see some great results.
It's actually coming out of a
opening the eyes universe like this,
that sandbox environment. There's
a lot of possibility here. Uh,
which makes me very excited about it.
Okay. Anyway, so what we're doing here is
mmm,
uh, noted. If Jess, Jess is a little
confusing for beginners. Noted. Okay.
So we're going to create, what am I doing
here? So I'm creating three variables,
right? Be Index the number of previous
neurons and in the layer that we're on,
which we're going to initialize because
we just created that using the index as
a brander. Okay? So what we're
about to do is, well, first of all,
we want to populate the layer because
we are creating a neural network.
This is going to create the
network itself, okay. By
creating a stack of layers.
Okay? Okay. So that's what we're doing.
Um,
uh,
I knew there would be a Westworld
reference at some point. Some of one,
one of my friends was like, dude,
you need to watch Westworld.
Someone on your channel
is going to mention it.
It's going to be great for
me and been references.
So you need to start watching it.
And Lo and behold,
someone has mentioned Westworld,
so I might need to check
up on that show. Anyway,
so,
so we've created our three variables here.
So let's populate the layer with the
inputs that we've already created.
Right up here, we have our
input, we have our, um,
let's see, we have our previous
number of neurons. Okay.
So each of our layers is going
to be populated just like that.
And we're going to add each layer to
our existing array of layers. Okay?
So later, that's that. And
then we went to the index.
We're going to iterate through the
index and the index tells us which layer
we're on. Okay? So we're going to iterate
that, that index a counter variable.
So now we're going to go, we're going
to iterate through every single, uh,
layer in our network. And we're going
to, we're going to add it to our,
uh, we're going to iterate through, sorry,
we're going to tech with a technical
term for this is we're going to iterate
through every single layer in our,
a list of layers and we're going
to add that to our network. Okay?
So we've stored a list of layers and we
want to add each of them to our network.
It's, we'll initialize our first layer
and this is for the number of hiddens.
And what do we mean by hiddens?
Hiddens is, uh, the, the,
the number of hidden layers that we've,
that we've specified in the parameter.
So we say,
so for each of these layers we went
up to populate it with a number of,
of kittens. Okay. Um,
oh, sorry. Never, no.
Let me Redo the UN. So what I just
said, undo that. It's not hidden.
It's not number of hidden layers. It's
number of hidden neurons. Okay. Um,
to answer your question bus card,
yes.
I will do a much more simple neural
network tutorial a, it's coming up.
It's going to be, uh, it's
coming up in January. Okay. So,
uh, so we were going to neutralize it by
using the number of hidden neurons and a
number of previous neurons. And why do
we want the number of previous neurons?
Well, we want to wait. We want
something to point to, right?
Because our weights are going
to be pointing. Okay. So,
uh, now we want to say, well,
now that we initialize that layer while
replace what we have in our previous
neurons with whatever we have in
our hiddens, right? Because we've,
we've propagated forward and we're,
we're replacing the old variable
with a what we've already done.
Okay.
So now we're going to push this layer
onto the list of layers and we're going to
iterate that index counter variable.
So let's look over what we've just done.
What we've just done is we've iterated
through a number of hidden neurons that
we were given into input parameter.
We have initialize a layer.
We have populated it with
those neurons. We've, uh,
set the previous neurons to whatever
we have, whatever we had now, uh,
and then we've pushed that layer
to the list of layers. Okay. Uh,
and so now that we've done that,
we'll create another layer.
And why do we want to create
another layer? Well, there's one,
there's one more thing
that we didn't think about.
We didn't think about the output.
Remember we,
we fed this function on out
a list of outputs, right?
That we want. So we want to create that
last layer for just the health, but right?
So as, so these are our
hidden layers, right?
So remember we created the first layer,
which is our input layer.
We create a list of,
sorry,
a list of hidden layers and now we're
creating art output layer. Okay?
So that's what we're doing
and we'll create it by, uh,
initializing with the number of output
neurons and then the number of previous
neurons. And lastly,
once we've created that,
we can just go ahead and push it to
our list of layers. That's it. Okay.
So our input neuron was created. Our list
of hidden, uh, sorry, our input layer,
our list of hidden layers,
and then our output layer.
Okay. So now we've done that.
We've created our network. Um, and
before we create our generation, uh,
before we do that,
we want to create a set of
a helper functions. Okay?
So the first one I want to do
is, is called compute. Okay?
So this is an important step. So, um,
computation step. Okay. So
let's do the computations step.
This is an important step and
it's a part of our network.
So what do I mean by computation?
Well, as data flows to our network,
it's not static. Uh, we're,
we're actually applying, uh, uh,
we're applying operations to it,
mathematical operations.
And I'm going to talk about what
these operations are. Okay? So,
so the first thing we're going to do is
we're going to check if the layer and
the neurons are not empty and if they're
not, we're going to assign it, uh,
the input value. So we're going to
check, we're going to say, okay,
so check each of those input values. Okay,
let me check ethers, those input values.
And I want to see if, uh, uh,
if the initial layer, uh, and the,
it's number of neurons. So I want to
see if it's number of neurons is empty.
That's what I'm looking for. Um, uh,
what's a neuron. Dot Neurons, uh,
and then wherever we are right now.
And so if there's something there,
then we want to add it to our, the
current, uh, layer that we're on
and we're going to say,
uh,
so whatever layer that we're currently
on, add all of those neurons to it. Uh,
and then, and it's going to
be those input values, right?
The input values. So, okay,
so that was that introductory step where
we actually filled that layer with,
with neurons. Okay. So now that we've
done that, now that we've done that,
now it's time to,
now it's time to actually
do the computation. Okay?
So what's happening here?
We're going to,
the data's going to flow to the layers.
I'm going to apply an
activation function to it,
and then we're going to return the
output. Okay? So let's do that. Uh,
activation function step. We're going
to say, okay, let's go to start off. Um,
this step is unclear. Okay. So
let me, um, let me see. Okay. So,
okay, so the function, so
let's, let's talk about this.
So what is happening here?
I am, what am I doing? I'm
updating the weights. Okay.
I'm updating the way to using
a sigmoid function. Exactly.
So someone said sigmoid. Exactly.
So that's exactly what I'm doing.
So what I'm gonna do is I'm going to
iterate through each of my neurons. Okay.
So let's, so, so let's see.
Iterate through neurons in layer.
Okay. So let me just say it. Iterate their
neurons in a layer. Okay. So for, um,
Vivar I equals one.
Uh,
and I is less than this,
the layers, the length,
and let me to, let me, when
did you better check a pistol?
I Lutyens it'll never change.
Let's see.
Outside the loop, since
it'll never change. MMM.
Actually, actually, um, that's a
good point. That's a good point.
And we could just do that if
we knew the size of, right.
So we could actually write
that differently. You're
right. That's a good point.
We could, we could write that
differently. It's still works,
but we could've written that differently.
Right? It's just a null check. Exactly.
Okay. So where was I? We want to iterate
through every neuron in the layer. Uh,
and where was I? So length, um,
and we've got iPad plots. Okay.
So what we're doing re iterate through
every neuron in each of our layers.
And we're going to do a double iteration.
So we're going to say four bars, j
four j and this dot layers.
Uh,
so for the length of the neuron and then
for each of the layers. Okay. So, um,
so for this stop layers, uh, where
was I was at? This isn't layers. I,
uh,
dot neurons then.
Where was I? Okay, so,
so the first thing, okay,
so let me talk about what we're
about to do. Well, before I do this,
I need to initialize this
variable called some,
and let me talk about
what some is going to do.
So we're going to initialize
a variable called some.
And with some is going to do is, uh,
that is what we're going to apply the,
the activation. We're going to use
to create the activation function.
So the sum is going to be if we
take the previous layers, neurons,
if we take the previous layer neurons,
wherever we are with that, um,
uh,
and then we take the value,
we're going to multiply that by
this layer a weights. So that were,
that were to the layer
that we're currently on.
We're going to multiply it by the
weights. So this salt layers, uh,
I uh,
doc neurons,
it's not as good as gradient descent.
Um,
I mean we haven't seen someone
do it as well as, you know,
state of the art, a gradient descent with
backdrop. Uh, but I mean, think about it.
I mean we, we've all been a in a,
in an evolutionary environment.
So I think there's still
hope for uh, uh, uh,
genetic programming in general. Okay.
So we're creating this, the sum,
right? And so this psalm is what
we're going to apply to the, um,
we're going to apply it to
the activation function.
So I've created this loop and I'm
going to say for each of those layers,
neurons, j. Dot. Value. I'm
going to say self duck options.
Okay?
So here's the activation function step.
So I take that activation function and
then the parameter is going to be the son
that I've just calculated.
So what happened here,
the activation function
is going to take the sum,
which is the combined weight of the
neurons in this layer. And I'm going to,
uh,
I'm going to,
run the activation function on that some,
and it's going to convert that
number into a probability.
And so the probability is going to help
the data decide where to flow. Okay?
It's going to decide where to flow. And
finally, once I'm done with all of this,
I can just say, well, now that
I've iterated through that layer,
make sure that the previous layer is now
the current layer where I, where I work,
right? Just was, okay.
Okay. So we've done that,
that activation step.
Um,
uh,
right? Okay. So let's go ahead
and write our genome now.
So our genome is just another word
for a being or a, you know, a,
a living,
a living being inside of our generation.
So each genome has its own neural
network, right? So if you or I,
or genomes, and we have our own neural
network. So we'll call this genome. Okay.
This function or this variable genome
and genome has a score and it has a,
uh, previous layer. Dot Neurons.
Dot value. Is it, is it, let's see.
Let's see.
MMM,
no. Okay. So, uh, for genome we're
going to say a score in the network.
Those are our two printers. And
okay. So now it's time to, um,
Jay does exist. Jay is a part of this
bar. J up here on line one 22. Okay.
So for far genome, I want to say, okay.
So it has a score and it
has its own network, right.
And the score is like where it's at in
the game and that's how it's going to,
that's how we are going to keep tracking
internally of how well it's doing and
decide whether or not we want it to
breed for the next generation. Okay. Uh,
so we know those are our two attributes
of score and it's network. Okay.
So that's a genome. And then now it's
time for that highest level object.
We're ready to code our generation.
And what is our generation?
A generation consists of several genomes.
Okay?
So at generation is just a list.
We can think of it as a list of genomes
and that's the only parameter that we
have. Uh, the number of genomes. Okay. Oh,
good call. Don't capitalize genomes.
Genomes to deter. Okay, great.
Uh, this stuff genomes and
it's an empty list, right?
So it's going to be an empty list.
Awesome fitness functions for the win.
Okay.
All right guys.
So let's go ahead and create our
function for adding the genome to our a
generation.
Okay.
So add the genome at a
genome torque generation.
So we need a function for this ad,
a genome to current generation.
Hey, let me just shut this
off for a second. Okay. Okay.
So for our current generation, Hi
guys. Hi everybody. Um, okay, so
let's go ahead and do this.
So for our generation,
we want a prototype that point to be
called add genome. That's what this is.
That's what this does. Okay. And we're
going to say, okay, so given a genome,
which is our parameter,
we want to add it to this generation,
that that's our task. So, um,
we're going to say,
um,
well we're going to say we're going
to iterate through a, wherever we are,
and we're going to say,
uh, I is less than, uh,
the length of the genome that
we're apps, which says, okay,
so what we want to do
right now is we want to,
uh, made sure that, uh, we are,
uh, we, we have sorted it, right? So
that's the first thing we want to do.
We want to sort it, and we don't want
to add a genome if it's not sortable.
So we're going to create a check for that.
We're going to iterate through the list
of genomes and we're going to check the
score. And if the score is less
than zero, so if it's a bad score,
then what we want to do is we, uh,
that's, that's the first check. Okay.
And there are two interjects.
So if there's, if it's less
than zero, and if this,
if the genome score is greater than what
we already have in our list of genomes
or rapes,
remember we have one in memory and then
we have one that we're looking at, uh,
gets greater than that score.
Then we just want to break because
it's not going to be a part,
it's not going to be in order.
Okay. So we want to break.
What's the other breaking? Uh,
what's the other edge case? There's,
there's one more edge case that we
want to code. And that edge case is,
let me back up a little bit and let
me say else if the genomes score
is less than where we currently,
uh, what we currently have.
If the genome score is less
than this genomes a score,
then we also want to break.
So remember,
we only want it to add it if it's
sorted and if it, and that this,
this prevents us from adding
things out of order. Uh,
and what do I mean by sorted?
We, we're sorting by the score.
We have a list of genomes and
they are sorted by their score.
So now we want to add our genome.
Okay. So this stuck genomes,
that splice. Okay. And
splice is the, uh, uh,
the verb that we're using to
add the genome tool to our, uh,
are our array of our list of genomes.
Okay.
So now let's write our breeding
function. Okay? So we've, we've,
once we've ticked the genome that we want,
the next step is to breed them.
So let's, let's say, okay,
it's time to breathe.
Time to breed that the down
time to breathe. Okay? So,
um, so that's what we're
going to do. And this is our,
uh, breeding function.
This is our last, uh,
major function that we're going to
write. Okay? So time's a breed. Ah,
let's go ahead and write this. Write out
this function. Okay. Stick with me guys.
We've got a, we're almost done. Okay.
So we're going to create a breeding,
uh,
uh, function. Okay.
And what does a breeding function
going to take as his cranberry? Well,
it's going to take two sets of weights,
okay.
The set of weights from one parent and
a set of weights from the other parents.
Um, okay, so we've probably got
about 10 more minutes. Okay.
So everybody relax, sit back, enjoy
the ride. Okay, so we're going to have,
um, and a number of children, right?
So these are our two parents and
in a number of children, okay?
That's what we're going to do. A Pan.
So we're going to do breed these two.
So remember, these are two
good networks, okay? We've,
we've identified them as good networks
because the scores that they provide are
over a certain threshold
that we predefined, okay?
So what we're gonna do is we're going to
iterate through the number of children,
okay? However many children we want
our at least parents to have, okay?
So we're going to say NB zero.
As long as it's less than a number
of children that you've defined,
we want to iterate through all of them
and we're going to of course iterate
through each of them.
All right?
So the first thing we want to do
is create our, uh, data variable.
And what does our data variable, dude,
well, we take, we use the Builtin, uh,
uh, Jason Function, uh,
Jason Builtin parts function to,
uh,
get the list of weights from
the first parent. And if so,
the weights are going to be just
a huge mishmash of numbers, right?
These are just a huge list of numbers.
It's a matrix of numbers,
but we want it to be machine
readable for readable. Right? Um,
and so if we want it to be readable,
then we're going to,
um, you know what? Uh, so he attached,
it seems complicated and I'm going to
get better and making it more accessible.
But you know,
it all depends on the syntax and this
could definitely be less complicated and
it will get less complicated over
time as I do more live streams.
So don't give up hope. Okay. Uh, and this
is definitely gonna get easier over time.
So Jason. Dot. Fi and what do
we string string applying? Um,
this is indeed a neuro evolution.
Uh, okay, so we're gonna.
So we're going to string a Fye the first
wait so that it's readable and we're
going to store it in a data variable.
Okay?
So now it's time for us to say,
ah, let's do a little bit of, of,
uh,
of mutations.
So we're going to take the first parent
and we're going to iterate through, uh,
every single list of weights
in our networks. Okay?
MMM. All right. So let's
go ahead and say, Gee,
not network a ways.
By the way,
you guys should next time for the next
live stream. I didn't tell you this time,
but you should totally be a coding along
with me. Okay? So maybe not this time,
but next time I want you all
to be coding along with me, uh,
in future livestreams. Okay. Uh, but
for right now, just, just, just, uh,
check this out.
So we're going to iterate through all
of the weights that we have. Okay.
We're going to iterate through every
single one of those weights and we want to
now perform some mutation, right? So in
order to mutate, we want to say, okay,
well let's arbitrarily define
some threshold. So we'll rent,
we'll randomly generates a
number using the math dot.
Random function. Okay, we'll,
we'll randomly generate that and we'll
say, well, if it's less than 0.5,
then we want to update our,
uh, our weights from our,
that we sorted our data variable,
right?
And the data variable is just a temporary
variable that's going to store our
weights and rep, right? So if it's,
if it's rent were arbitrarily and
randomly going to update those weights.
Um,
now we've created teacher.network
and we're going to,
we're going to add all this weight from
Jeetu. Okay, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
So there's that. And so now we're
going to add some mutation to each way.
And so now here's the, here's
the, here's the fun part.
We're going to perform
to mutation. And, um,
so, uh, we've, we've mutated.
So what's happened? Uh,
we've mutated the weights in
the temporary data variable, uh,
using one of the parents, the
weight of one of the parents, g two,
and now we want to update the weights.
Um,
given, uh, this other, so they're
here. Here's our other arbitrarily.
Okay. So a note it. So I need to
heavily, heavily comics the code.
Okay. So math dot random, uh,
less than or equal to. So,
okay, so what do we have here?
So one of our hyper parameters
was called the mutation rates. Um,
the mutation rate defined like
how fast do we want to mutate?
So that's the kind of the arbitrary think
are arbitrary number we're looking at.
Um,
but we basically want to say like,
take those weights and update
them by adding a whatever,
random,
a random variable times
whatever our mutation ranges.
Um, right. So like that's going to be,
and we can tune that differently and
that's going to give us different results,
like for the mutation rate. Uh, and
then we want you subtract the range.
So we want it to be within
a certain range. Okay.
But we've added some mutation.
And now finally we can go ahead and
say we've added our mutation, go ahead.
And what we've just created a list of
mutated weights toward data is variable.
And at the very end, which you
go ahead and return. So let me,
let me write a comment as well.
Return the list of Brita genomes.
These are the genomes that have been
bred. So these are the updated, uh, uh,
more advanced, stronger,
more robust neural networks,
and that's just going
to keep going into our,
each new generation and they're
going to get better over time. Okay,
so let's have Brita genomes
and we want to return to that.
Okay? So that's the, that's the winner.
That's the code that we're going to do.
Let me go,
go,
go all the way up and I'm going to do a
short walk through what I've just done.
Um, and so let me, uh,
so remember this is the
link to the demo code.
If you guys want to see it on the web.
I showed at the beginning,
and let me show it again, uh, for a
second. It is the game of asteroids.
It looks like this,
right?
So many of them are generated many little
spaceships and they're all trying out
different things every time.
And you can see them all dying.
And once they're all dead, new ones will
spring up. Okay. So it's just like that.
And so let me explain
what's happening here. Okay.
So we're using something called neuro
evolution, neuro evolutions at technique,
okay? And this is, so here's,
here's how we starting off. Okay.
We want to create our
neuro evolution variable.
Then our lists of neurons are layers.
Our network,
our genome and our generation's. It
gets bigger and bigger. Each member,
each object gets bigger and bigger.
So it's a type of reinforcement learning
because we are learning in real time
from what the game is giving being us.
Okay?
So we will initialize our neural
evolution, uh, variable, well, well,
all of our hyper parameters that are
going into a dark going to signify of how
we're going to generate these, uh,
uh, new neural networks. So remember,
every spaceship has its own neural
network, will define our set of options.
And we'll start out by initializing
our net neuron, our neuron variable.
Each neuron has its value
and a set of weights. Okay?
And we went to randomly initialized
each of those weights for each of those
neurons.
Okay?
And once we've created a neuron will
create a layer and a layer has an ID and a
number of neurons,
which started off as zero,
but then we'll populate the layer
by adding every neuron, uh, uh,
by however many would define like number
of neurons. Then we'll create a network.
And a network consists of a number of
layers, which we just defined previously,
which contains a number of neurons.
And we're going to generate that layer
by first generating the, and let me,
let me, let me add a comment here.
This is, um, uh, input layer, right?
The input layer.
Then we create our hidden layers and then
our output layer by using those three
parameters that were given
input hiddens and outputs. Okay.
And then we have a computation step.
This is where we actually
apply the activation function
in each neuron of every
layer in our network, we
turn those numbers into
probabilities of the score of,
and the weights of, of, uh, of,
of, of the, of each of the bots.
And each of those is a genome, right?
That's how we define them. As each,
as a genome and a generation contains a
selection of genomes and we want to add
a genome to the current network.
I'm making sure that it's sorted in order
and you will use a splice function to
add it.
And lastly,
we'll breed our network by taking
the weights of one of our parents,
uh,
mutating it,
and then creating an entirely new set
of weights in the state of variable, uh,
by mutating the other one.
And then we'll return the list of those
weights and what we can use those ways
to up update the next generation
of, uh, of neurons. Okay.
So now let me end the screen
sharing. Okay. All right.
So we'll do a last minute,
uh,
last Q and a and then we're done
for the day. All right, so any,
any last, last questions? Go
for it. Ask me anything. Um,
why does it need to be thwarted?
And he said it's so, it's,
it's better for computational complexity.
If it's foreign it, then we can, uh, it's,
it's going to be a retrieval is going
to be faster retrieval for this force.
Um, so that's just for
computational complexity.
Does it make sense a change in network
and put what genetic algorithm? Uh, yes,
absolutely.
Um,
well the network input is already going
to change because the Games are dynamic.
Um, uh, right. So there's that.
What screen sharing app do you use?
I use Google hangouts. I guess you owe
us a wrap now. You're absolutely right.
I mean decide what to rap about. Someone
said something about care Os. Uh, Yo,
I'm going to do this without
it being okay. Here we go. Um,
I was trying out care Roth man. My life
is so lost. I'm sitting here in Portland,
man, what is this? It's
like, I don't want to curse,
but horror horrorlands not really.
And things are going wrong.
My mind is so loose that
I'm going all around. Okay.
So that was that.
Wow Man.
Got that Portland jam happening
right now it's on point.
It is 10:00 AM on a, on
a Wednesday. Everybody,
it is 10:00 AM on a Wednesday for me.
So that's, that's what happened. Um,
uh, so that was my impromptu rep
and how am I, I'm doing good.
Am I going to test it? I'm
going to add the code to the,
uh, link description. Okay.
So remember to check it out. Um, that just
happened Brian. You're absolutely right.
That just happened. It is a place. Um,
I'm going to shoot an
experimental video here and cool.
One more question and we're good to go.
Is there an easy way to save the data
that's created by the network, um,
in order to implement, in order
to implement it? Uh, yeah, no,
the data is saved and the data is variable
and it's just a list of weights and
we can, um, we can use those weights to
update other types of networks as well.
And that's that, that would be a
part of transfer learning. Okay.
So we could learn from one game and then
ideally applied those weights to any
game. And that's what deepmind did
for the Atari DQ learner. Okay.
Um, do you have a job? No,
this is my job data set of
all reddit comments available.
Anything in the future?
I'm sure I'm going to do something with
a red, uh, comments. Uh, I'm not, uh,
in India. My parents are from
India. I was born in Houston, Texas,
and now I live in San Francisco,
California. I'm new to the channel.
What languages do you use?
Mostly Python and javascript and ah,
cool. Okay guys. Uh, uh, Tara
didn't use a neuro evolution. Uh,
they use something called the DQ learner.
Okay. Uh, right now I've got to go.
Um, did I dye my hair? Yes.
What's new for 2017? Uh,
my opus magnum opus, magnum, uh, my
beautiful dark, twisted fantasy, uh,
which is this new machine learning course,
which I'm not going to say much about,
but just know that something big is
coming guys. Okay. Um, cool. So yeah,
that's it for this livestream. Um, uh,
thank you guys so much for showing up.
I'll add the coaching, the comments.
I love all of you. Thanks for showing up.
Uh, during Christmas. I know, you know,
you have a, a lot of things that can be
doing. So, uh, for now I've got to go,
uh, Heiko waterfall, so thanks
for watching. I love you guys.